greetings apiece welcome to the Dean
show this week we're going to be talking
about the people's champ America's hero
our hero your hero American Muslim
Muhammad Ali some great highlights from
his life where he expounded it true he
stood on a truth and he shared the truth
also did you know a hot seller what was
the hot seller for many of these
radicals that ignorant people try to
link back to Islam was was it some great
scholarly reference that would expand on
their great knowledge of Islam no kiss
what it was it was Islam for dummies and
I got a better book that I recommend
it's actually by an American revert it's
called a complete idiot's guide to
understanding Islam because you've got
to be a complete idiot if you're going
to somehow try to connect this mentally
deranged psychopath American radical
homosexual to Islam to these barbaric
and criminal evil acts that Muslims
abhor and detest that Islam condemns
Muslims condemn and our sympathy and
condolences go out to the families and
the victims and we're going to be
talking about all this and more here on
this week's show of the Dean show don't
go anywhere it will be right back this
is the
this is the thing you know this is the
days of the theme you know this is the
jewel Salaam alaikum peace be with you
dr. sabir how are you walaikum assalaam
wareham de llegar al hamdulillah all
praise be to Allah subhanAllah this is
the same thing that Muhammad Ali would
always say first of all oh thank
Almighty God Allah feel Hank of my town
of the praising million ghost oh he
would say thank God Almighty Allah this
was something that was common with him
he was doing the DA was sharing the
message but not even 36 hours after the
world got to see Islam in is true light
got to see the memory of Muhammad Ali
chanting is America's hero we have this
tragic event that just happened best PR
campaign for Islam that we've seen in so
long unifying people you saw rabbis
coming to speak I come here speaking as
representative of American Jews and that
we today stand in solidarity with
Islamic community in this country and
all around the world we will not
tolerate politicians or anyone else
putting down Muslims and blaming Muslims
for a few people
on his behalf you saw preachers you saw
people from all different nationalities
coming to go ahead and share their
wonderful experiences with this great
man but now you have this The Tragically
totally taken away from what we got to
see of beauty what do you what do we
have to say about the snake bismillahi
r-rahmani r-rahim peace and blessings on
prophet muhammad sallallahu leave Salem
we as Muslims whenever we see a tragedy
like happen in Orlando we condemn it in
the clearest office but in the same
condemnation it's very very important
for all of us to condemn any violence
done by anyone using any weapon for any
ideology because I hope I realized that
all of us know all life is equal every
bloody sacred and every soul is precious
so when we condemn any violence done by
a Muslim on anyone else we should
equally condemn all violence like for
example four hundred and six thousand
violent attacks using guns killing
innocent people so we should condemn it
because these are also human beings are
also equal so it's very important that
yes Muslims we condemn it we will keep
on condemning it he does not stand for
Islam what stands for Islam is obviously
the noble example of Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him the wonderful guidance
from the Quran and that's what Muhammad
Ali stood for yeah you can see that in
his life and if people look at him and
they'll want to stand behind him I mean
this is what the majority of Muslim
stand behind but why do you think is you
know the double standard you have
somebody who his wife ex-wife this
person who did this horrific act they
say that he was deranged he was sick his
father when questioned he said Lee that
someone says it that radicalized he
wasn't because he had no beer you know
he didn't have a beard so he so he
couldn't be radicalized
somehow other elements want to connect
it somehow to Islam you know obviously
this has nothing to do with Islam why do
you think this double standards always
is there it's like there's an agenda
being pushed yeah it appears like that
right whenever you see a Muslim commit
committing an act they always want to do
more research to find out if there is a
connection but if someone else doesn't
act like what happened in that school
shooting what happened in that theater
shooting what happened in that plant
family shooting people don't want to
look into their religion they want to
don't dig too much to see if there is a
connection with Christianity with some
other groups but when it comes to
Muslims doing some shooting they always
wants to make that connection so we are
not saying that Muslims are all perfect
what we are saying is that it's very
very important they are good and bad
apples in the followers of any ideology
but Islam stands for peace and justice
and equality so if you are going to read
the Quran you are going to find out that
Quran in a very clear way condemns acts
of violence for example in Chapter
number 5 verse number 32 our Creator is
saying that taking one innocent life is
like taking the life of all of humanity
and saving one life is like saving the
life of all of humanity and that was
what the Prophet preached that was the
way that hill lived and that's what
Muhammad Ali right the great boxer
that's what he also preached to the
people i think the the solution to this
is education i mean once people I mean
this is what really my personal stories
when I start to really study Islam I
start to see the love mercy compassion
to justice that was there then I started
to see on TV the complete antithesis the
opposites being promoted as it man I
have to get up and try to make a
difference but it was through education
and this is what Muhammad Ali his whole
mission you can see he was you know my
one of my first teachers you also knew
him dr. amir ali he would tell us that
Muhammad Ali would come in and he would
take these brochures and pamphlets and
he would sign his name on it and he
would distribute this and through
educating
making that human connection with
humanity with our brothers and sisters
and humanity they will see that this is
opposite to some and the Muslims when
they get educated someone might have
some zeal because there's a lot of
obviously and justices that are going on
and in no way is this condoned taking
innocent life but what is your thoughts
now education being the key and let's go
take off from there how Muhammad Ali he
lived on educating people on what Islam
was really about yeah we all know that
mashallah he was a great boxer perhaps
one of the greatest he was a good civil
rights leader he was a good husband he
was a good father but beyond and all of
these things he was a good sharer of
Islam because there's our field whenever
we see someone who is passionate about
Dawa hearing the message the message of
peace it resonates so it's important
that Muhammad Ali peace be upon him
right peace of God and mercy of God be
upon him he used to take brochures like
these and used to sign the brochures we
actually have one right here and there
we go this is a brochure over here with
a signature here so each single day
doesn't matter you know how sick he was
which has Parkinson's disease he used to
make the effort used to sign like 500
plus brochures a single day when used to
go out with the for a walk with his
family members with somebody's help
people used to come and identify him in
the crowd and he still and these two
requesting for autographs right because
he was a famous person instead of
writing the autograph on their paper he
has to take the brochure and give it to
them so with the autograph a message of
Islam is going to their homes and
inshallah they are going to read it and
they will know what Islam is the faith
of justice and peace and equality so
there's a wonderful way so brother Eddie
one important lesson that I have learned
from this and perhaps you too is that
there could be many many challenges
coming challenges could be from outside
challenges could be from inside it could
be from our health our wealth or any
other ways but any blessing that a las
monitor has given to us even a drop of
blessing we have to use it the best way
possible to share this wonderful message
of Islam
and that was one of the ways that our
dear friend Muhammad Ali did despite his
sickness he knew he could still sign and
he used that for the sake of Islam and
that was out of his deep love and we
talked about Mohammed Ali for Prophet
Muhammad alas the final messenger sent
to mankind and I was out of his deep
love for the creator of mankind we got a
lot more to talk about here in the Dean
Showtime Muhammad Ali the American hero
who was actually a Muslim like Jesus was
one who submits to the will of the
creator of heavens and earth will be
right back down go anywhere but if I
told you to this glass sprung into
existence this glass made itself no man
made this glass if you leave it would
you believe I told you this thing made
itself when I tell you you would be
right no some somebody's deltic again so
I'm giving it up so that she would leave
if I Turner this television station it's
popped into existence it just no man
made it he said Muhammad Ali's crazy
well this glass can't make yourself if I
told you those clothes you have on wove
themselves nobody created them those
clothes made themselves
but if your if your clothes didn't make
itself if that glass couldn't make
yourself if this building then make
yourself then how did the moon get out
there how do the stars and Jupiter
Neptune and bars from the Sun how to
nature how I long discover if didn't
know why is something planning to Meghan
so what I'm saying is I believe that we
will be judged should a man like hitler
kill all the jews and get away with it
somebody's at punish you maybe get it
don't get in there you get it moved on
in hell for eternity so what I'm gonna
do when I get out of boxes is to get
myself ready to meet God because my
plane might blow up don't planes go up
in this country some time to crash no
people die every day of not a day it's a
scary thing to think that I'm going to
hell to burn eternally fella so what am
I going to do weasel taking such well
I'm explained with jasmine question you
ask the questions I can't just answer
like it when i get out of boxer know
when I'm through I'm going to do all I
can to help people that's why I made
with Johnnie Walker her as a poor man
came all the way to Michael because a
bunch of boys need some money and
somebody's calling me to help him not as
much of me God is God don't praise me
because I beat Joe Frazier God don't
give them about Joe Frazier that'll kind
of bubble engli Marika's far as real
wealth is all he is he wants to know how
do we treat each other how to be healthy
back here on the DS show where we
talking about the American hero who
actually was a Muslim many people still
don't know that you know even though his
name is Muhammad Ali some people still
you know that's how I informed many
people are they don't know about you
know when they really find out just what
a Muslim means it's one who surrenders
and submits two god it's not someone
who's an Arab this is not someone who's
from India Muslims are from all walks of
life and just people who have chosen to
live a life like Muhammad Ali was living
preparing being conscious that death is
coming it's approaching and we have to
be the best in paying like he had a
quote that your your rent here on this
earth what did he say was his is giving
back now to humanity and that's what we
need to do and he was doing that by
educating humanity I want to get off on
this one those are people who end up the
really small fringe element that the
media loves to put up on a pedestal and
exemplify like they like they exemplify
Islam obviously this is totally the
opposite Islam many of them that fringe
element who have gone over to commit
certain evil acts you know what the
number one book was that these people
would go ahead and purchase on amazon
it's LA for dummies dummies for
Islamiyah Islam for dummies that's what
it was so that tells you a lot that's
what I goes back to education being
educated obviously these people and your
party who does is not just the dummies
is deranged and is doing opposite and
they can actually win a one-way ticket
to the Hellfire by killing innocent
human beings but education that goes
back how important this is and let's
continue on with Muhammad Ali and you
know some of the great services he did
as a Muslim trying to better mankind
right right so it's very important that
he stood for the principles not consoles
will let me go shoot my brother are some
darker people are some poor hungry
people in the mud
a big powerful America and shoot them
for what they never called me Neil they
never less be there for no dogs will be
there Robbie mouth nice dolly great
killed my mother father well shoot him
for what I are gonna shoot them little
pool of black people no babies and short
or whatever how much shootin pool people
i'll just take me to jail but it was not
a good thing to do or it was he risked
his his title he risked his name his
famous money to stand out for the
principles so it's very important when
he changed his faith from being a
Christian to a Muslim to submit to the
Creator he changed his name from Cassius
Clay to Muhammad Ali because he wants to
show to the people his Muslim identity
the new faith and especially the new
name the name muhammad peace of God be
upon him by prophet muhammad peace be
upon him so there's one way that he
wants to share with the people that
islam is a good faith peaceful faith
looking to it I am Muhammad Ali right so
there's one wonderful way he would say
he would say look you guys know me I'm a
Muslim 20 years go against killing
pounds and all Muslims I guess think
people should know to hear truth about
Islam you know me I'm a boxing and call
the greatest about people recognizing
together fox and a mana children and I
wouldn't be here she's never seen this
one it was really like the tears made it
look I think
all the people should know the truth and
come to recognize tuned because this
love is peace against killing Merlin in
the tears the people told that name is
wrong and if I had chance I'd do some
bad so now who you going to believe you
know there's an ayah in the Quran where
God Almighty is talking about when a
deceitful person comes to you with news
do your research check it up verify it
yeah you know we see in the media a lot
of times we say no no you can't you know
people are having the message of Islam
distorted the image of Muslims you don't
see them propagating all the good you
know and usually it's some fringe
element does something deranged want to
give all 1.6 billion Muslims a bad name
but at the same time the media nowadays
shouldn't we also think more not to let
just be program and to swallow
everything that is being fed to him as a
law is telling us in the crunch check it
out verify don't just blindly follow it
what are your thoughts on that yes it's
very important they're good and bad
apples in the followers of any faith yes
so they are some Muslims who are
committing these acts so it's very
important we should not judge a faith by
some misguided followers if we do that
then we have to discredit all the face
and all the ideologies which are out
there and that doesn't make sense then
Christians unfortunately so there are
some bad Christians or followers of the
Bible followers of Jesus and followers
of Christianity who have done heinous
act all throughout history but I
personally and perhaps you too and the
Muslims we don't blame Christianity for
the accident by the Christians for
example the person in Norway he killed
like 78 people in the name of
Christianity innocent people he just
went there any shard the people and he
wrote this memo in there the Bible is
mentioned the crosses mentioned Jesus
Christ peace be upon him is mentioned
but we are saying people we don't want
the whole Christianity responsible for
what he did in the same way doesn't
matter if people mentioned the name
Allahu Akbar if they mentioned the name
jihad they want to throw credibility to
a cause doesn't matter what name that
they use when they're doing heinous act
if the Act goes against the Quran and
the example of prophet muhammad peace be
upon him we reject those acts yes tell
me this we're going to get back to
Muhammad Ali there was our friend our
Jewish friend Andrew who was with us and
then I don't know the other gentleman he
was there he was a nice man but it
seemed like he was watching a lot of the
fox news and other the other you know
media outlets and we had a discussion
before we can get into it actually our
Jewish friend Andrew he was giving
statistics and facts can you go ahead
and relate the shoe store in some areas
really unique situation we had there so
right after the meeting is we step
outside of the public library we found
out this person who is supposedly a
supporter of Donald Trump he was saying
all these nasty things about Islam about
Muhammad peace be upon him about Sharia
law and we found out that you know he
has a very narrow vision based upon what
we what he's seen on the fox news and
some charm which is reiterating
basically you know the sauce propagation
force a Jewish guy the Jewish guy who
was under the meeting andrew he found
out that you know this person is
confronting us with all of this
misinformation he shot him down with
fast fit facts but they're not emotional
it's not a very important he said you're
entitled to your opinion but not your
own facts x he kept exactly that was
such a good way of saying it so then
this Jewish person who is a good person
right and he said that I know the
Muslims and Muslims are good people
there are peaceful people and there was
a profound statement I mean I could
shout it through the roof top so many
times but a person was not a follower
assist Islam especially a Jewish person
seeing that to a Christian a follower of
Trump it has a profound meaning to it it
has a profound impact of it that was
deep that was deep and he was he was
relating the groups that are actually
doing far more harm to them to Tomas and
he actually America then Muslims at all
you know when you look at the statistics
and then you started dropping statistics
on him you know the 90 what is it the
only the four four percent
have anything from the ninety-six
percent according to the FBI statistics
and the other Europol's statistics etc
etcetera it doesn't add up you have more
of a chance of getting hit by light and
killed by lightning secondhand smoke
than you do by supposing muslim terre by
toddlers or by toddlers grabbing a
parent's gun and shooting huh so it's
very important since we're on the topic
then we'll move to Muhammad Ali topic
really quickly it's very important that
those people are those Muslims they are
reacting apparently according to them
that the in justices let's talk about
those oh so we have to go to break right
there don't lose your place we're going
to continue right there within justices
and in no way does Islam condone it
condemns the senseless acts of violence
against innocent men women and children
we'll be right back don't go anywhere
you don't want to miss out you want to
be here every Friday and then we'll try
to give you some short reminders in
between but you can't get that if you're
not coming back to the show every week
Friday's will be releasing it God
willing inshallah subscribe right now
and enjoy all of the content that we're
going to be putting out for you thank
you peace be with you so I'm like
back here on the Dean show Mohammed Ali
he was a man of principle he stood for
truth stood for preparing as so many
times he talked about preparing for the
next life by doing good by serving
humanity and you had so many people come
and testify to this and he also he stood
for the Palestinian cause and there was
also many Jewish rabbis who came also
stand for you know justice and have
called upon the United States to stand
up to you up to the part of the Israeli
government that is oppressing
Palestinians is that is that we as Jews
understand that our commitment is to
recognize that God has created everyone
and that everyone is equally precious
and that means the Palestinian people as
well as all other people on the planet
let's go ahead and continue where you
left off before we want to break so it's
very important that if we are going to
root out any extremism any violence by
anyone by the way it's very important
for us to look at the cause why they are
doing what they're doing it's not just
what they're doing it's why they are
doing so when we look at the history of
the Boston bomber or the person or the
people who are doing the nasty things up
there almost all the cases they will let
you know they're doing this because in
justices the dictatorship the drone
missiles the air strikes there are
killing innocent people up there so it
is their anger it is there feeling of
vengeance which is being directed
towards violence so bombs are not going
to take away the anger what is going to
take away the anger is doing justice is
being equal with them not having double
standards that's not an excuse by the
way for what they are doing even if they
have the all the injustices in the world
even then Islam says that you cannot
harm you cannot touch you cannot kill
innocent people and that's those are the
teachings of Islam yes dr. papay papay
from the University of I believe I
Chicago he was terrorism expert he
looked at many of these terrorists ass
over a thousand of them and at the end
he concluded that Islam had little to
nothing to do with these suicide
bombings which didn't even exist as you
mentioned before 2000 2003 not a single
act of suicide bombing in the history of
Iraq but after the invasion happened
there in 2003 and all the embargoes and
the drone missiles then the whole
country went in the downward spiral
that's what dr. pop a professor puppy
talks about these are all due to foreign
invasions these are consequence at the
end not condoning aslam still condemns
it but this is what we need to talk
about the route the reaction that had
negative reaction but this is the
reaction you know 16 years of bombing
and 16 years of drone missile 16 years
of occupation is not going anywhere yes
we may continue those things but you
have to look at some other route way
root cause a better
Lucien humanity goes with the checks and
balances they go with the you know cause
and effect when you do justice there
would be peace so there's a very
important thing so coming back to
Muhammad Ali it's very important that
how he honored the name of Prophet
Muhammad peace be I was really amazing
yes when the Hollywood Chamber of
Commerce they approached him in the year
2000 to seeing that we want to honor
your name by have it having a star on
the Hollywood Walk of Fame he said no
thank you because he knew that his name
would be on the ground along with other
names and people may trample on the name
of Muhammad peace be upon him so he said
the only way you could honor be my name
up there is to not have it on the ground
so they compromised and he they had his
name on the wall so this is the only
name that nobody ever trampled on that
is the name muhammad peace be upon him
and this is named after the last and
final mission is a problem ahamad peace
be upon him who was the brother to Jesus
Moses Abraham because they all about to
say message submit to the Creator not
the creation Muhammad Ali in your
discussion with this gentleman me you
and Andrew I forgot the other person's
name he also another flimsy argument
people bring up is the oppression of
women and putting them down and you
actually flipped it and you talked about
how people in other places they actually
feel sorry for the women who are being
exploited here and Muhammad Ali also we
know his stance on modesty and whatnot
so if you could put those two that goes
back that's basically he's because
that's reiterating that the dignity the
elevation that Islam is given to the
woman not to exploit her like some piece
of meat right and we see that happening
and you actually refuted this argument
the man had and Muhammad Ali also talks
about this case so one day Muhammad Ali
he he came home to his home and he saw
his daughter Hannah and she was home so
she was not properly dressed so after
looking at her he said in Ohana looking
at her eyes he said that do you know
pearls they are way down deep in the in
the shells about diamonds how about gold
you have to work hard to get to them
because they are so precious in the same
way you
life is precious so you should also be
covered in making that analogy he
connected with her and he made the world
know that Islam stands also besides
justice and peace and morality it stands
for morale it stands from modesty
modesty not just for the men but also
for the women modesty not for the
clothes but what we see with our eyes
what we hear with our ears our tongue
our the rest of the body so Islam isn't
about connecting with the Creator
following his guidance working for peace
and justice the way Muhammad Ali used to
do so if you and me we love this person
Muhammad I did the great boxer we have
to also submit to the Creator the way
that he did the family of Muhammad Ali
if you love him and obviously do carry
on the legacy of Muhammad Ali bypassing
the brochures and being the message if
you want to meet him up there let's
follow the same fate the way that he
used to follow and may God have mercy on
Muhammad Ali forgive his sins and give
him the highest place in paradise I mean
we know that there's nobody passing out
visas to the Hellfire or to paradise
except the Creator to heavens RF this is
the one who is at the end admitting
people by His mercy to paradise and he's
it'd be unfair if he didn't have a way
for us to follow a system and we had
them hamid ali was following that system
of sammy of complete submission and
surrender as God Almighty is saying in
the Quran that the wom a habit
aggregated Islam adenine fillet you
cobalamin hua horfield al-qaeda Tamina
huh seeing this is one of the miracles
of the Quran I'm not I'm not Arab but
it's memorized by millions all over
aspiring to memorize pieces of it whole
chunks of eight chapters of it and and
and millions have memorizes complete
book so we have it in its original and
in the quran allah saying that whoever
chooses another way except submission
surrendered to God to the Creator alone
not worshiping a stick of stone a man a
woman nothing in Korea but God Almighty
and believing in his messengers and all
the other things that come along that
person will be guaranteed paradise so
for his family friends someone wants to
be
reunited with their loved ones wants the
pleasure of God we have to be obeying
God and this is what you know the legacy
of problem ahamed Jesus Moses and a
sincere servant like Muhammad a servant
of God like Muhammad Ali was so to
continue that what's the message at the
end we should aspire to share which is
part to live that purpose of life that
was sent by the crater you know just
like when you are working somewhere
there's certain assignment you have to
do to get the check at the end of the
day when you're going to school you have
to obey and listen to the professor and
follow the sign mean for you to pass in
the same way this whole life is a life
of test and trial and God is giving us
this wonderful guidance the Quran and
the example of Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him so by obeying the Creator
acknowledging he alone is the creator
and following his guidance that's the
way that God guarantees a person by His
mercy eternal paradise so we hope and
pray that just like Moses Abraham
Muhammad Jesus peace be upon all of them
the way that they followed the way that
they showed the way for us if we follow
the same principles oneness of God
following God's guidance as mentioned in
the Quran inshallah God willing you and
me and all of humanity would have the
best place in this world with justice
and peace and the best place in the
hereafter we're out of time we got one
minute left is there anything else about
Muhammad Ali's life we wanted to
specifically talk about this then we had
this this tragic event happened we as
many they'll say look why don't you guys
condemn it you know we always condemned
these things is very clear but sure
Muslim always have to be apologizing for
something that we have no part of well
it's very important that we don't expect
every single Church or every Caucasian
person every African or Mexican person
to apologize not apologize or to condemn
every single act of violence done by
their community members we don't because
we know that's wrong we show sympathy
and condolences to those who are
suffering yeah yes so it's very
important that a general statement can
be made by the Muslims that is we
condemn all violence done by anybody by
following a in the
name of any ideology using any weapon
and it should not have any expiration
date to that statement right that you
what do you think about this term its
core now radical Islam can aslam be
radical a person can be radical but
there is only one Islam that is a Islam
of peace and justice and morality and
equality for all a Christian can be
radical a Christian can be you know
extremist a Muslim can be extremists but
the religion itself the faith of Islam
is only one no such thing is radical
there is no such thing as a radical
Islam a progressive Islam on liberal
Islam or Sunni Shia Islam there's only
one Islam and that one Islam is the one
brought by prophet muhammad peace be
upon him submission to one God Quran and
following the example of Muhammad peace
be upon him and that is the Islam that
is going to give us justice and peace in
this world and purpose in life and in
sha allah paradise in the hereafter
beautiful thank you very much we're out
of time we started with peas women peach
so I'm a computer with you found anybody
got them ok my friend's dad was Muhammad
Ali his life his legacy now let's close
it up a few more points that I want to
highlight I'm going to go ahead and take
it to a clip of some pastors I know this
is very sensitive now but I want to
drive a point home of the double
standard the hypocrisy let's go to it
and then I'll give you my thoughts
afterwards but at sacramento's Verity
Baptist Church pastor Roger Jimenez told
his church goers what have you asked me
hey are you sad that 50 pedophiles were
killed today um no I think that's great
I I think that helps society you know I
think orlando florida is a little safer
tonight now that 50 you know the tragedy
is that more women die I mean the
tragedy is I'm kind of upset that he
finish the job everybody Pastor Steven
Anderson here from faithful Word Baptist
Church in Tempe Arizona and I just
wanted to record a quick video about the
news this morning about the shooting in
orlando i guess a muslim terrorist went
into a gay bar and shot him up and
there's 50 sodomites homosexuals that
have been
killed and another 50 some odd injured
and then the the Muslim guy himself was
was shot by the police it sounds like
and here's the good news and the bad
news about this you know the good news
is that there's 50 less pedophiles in
this world because you know these
homosexuals are a bunch of disgusting
perverts and pedophiles that's who was a
victim here are a bunch of just
disgusting homosexuals at a gay bar okay
and then I'm sure it's also going to be
used to push an agenda against so-called
hate speech so bible-believing Christian
preachers who preach what the Bible
actually says about homosexuality that
it's vile that it's disgusting that
they're reprobates you know we're gonna
be blamed like oh it's it's it's all
extremism it's not just the Muslims it's
the Christians do you have any regrets
about your statements during your sermon
on Sunday I don't have any regrets about
what I said and I don't take anything
back I would never take things into my
own hands have become a vigilante but I
will say this you know the Bible says
that homosexuals should be put to death
in Leviticus 2013 now the question is
what if these were Muslims we got to be
fair all across the board if you're a
journalist if you're in the media if you
are someone out there who has a social a
civil responsibility let's take a lesson
from Muhammad Ali he stood on truth he
stood on solid ground and at the end
what he came out victorious he was
blacklisted probably considered an enemy
of the state at that time just like
Martin Luther King Malcolm X but now you
have days holidays named after him he's
an American Muslim hero Muhammad Ali so
stand for truth report the truth don't
go ahead and twist the truth let's go to
another example you know this gentleman
James whole why nobody talking about him
this guy plotted and was planning with
weapons and chemicals to make a bomb he
was on his way to blow up a parade why
nobody mentioned in him his religion is
not mentioned nothing these guys these
sociopaths mentally disturbed people
they end up doing something man you look
nothing's mentioned about
religion they're happy whole entire
segments to look into the history of his
life what kind of childhood he had you
don't think we have also in a community
of over 1.6 billion you got people who
are also not functioning properly up
here they're a product of their
environment you have what's glorified
nowadays violence and the music in the
movies why don't we get together and try
to change and make a difference here I
mean you don't have someone who is an
American and someone does these mass
shooting now every American has to go
when he's overseas in Germany wherever
else he's traveling he has to go ahead
and apologize for all the American
criminals that are out there it does he
what about somebody shares the same name
as you never met this person he just has
the same last name max well whatever the
case you have to apologize with this
person named Maxwell who cares your same
last name him not even related to you
you have to apologize for him why then
with Islam why then move Islam why the
double standard because it's an agenda
people you see Islam is under attack we
know that that's a fact but the fiction
is that Islam is a threat Muslims are a
threat if anyone sincerely looks at the
data looks at the reports looks at the
statistics this is a boogeyman has been
created a false narrative that's being
perpetuated and pushed you as a sincere
individual who is seeking to know the
truth you will see that you have more of
a chance of being killed by a toddler
with a gun or by your furniture this
whole myth that's been created that now
wall-to-wall coverage Islamic radical
terrorists this is something that is
far-fetched and beyond its hype you have
more of a threat from functioning
organizations you know there's almost
like 200 KKK organizations function
these people if they had their reign
they be lynching massacre and killing
and you have other organizations
right-wing zealots that are out there
and you don't hear much of this at all
we talked about the hiroshima on the
light switch this guy was planning to
with a met weapon of mass destruction to
rain havoc in the society very little
news coverage but anyone with a muslim
name satwa for muslim had any connection
to a Muslim in Islam you see what's
happening wyd Wayne spectrum all over
the news so much hype and you know what
is to promote a political agenda create
fear and when you have that fear people
give up their rights certain agendas get
pushed and you just been bamboozled
that's it here's the point let me close
it up you know just in the Chicago my
hometown we just had 40 I just had a
mass shooting at least is seven killed
according to authorities and some 46
others injured in shootings over the
weekend not call us at this number if
you still if you have some questions
some queries you have some doubts 1 866
to Islam operators are standing by if
you have some apprehensions some
questions some doubts some
misunderstandings that's what we're here
for make the human connection don't be
on the side of hate be on the side of
understanding of love creating a
connection between us because we are not
going anywhere my brothers and sisters
we're here and we need to work to get to
know our neighbors instead of hating our
neighbors just like the Christians are
here the Muslims are here and the others
are here we have to work together in
unison we have to work together to make
the world that we live in as a better
place as Muhammad Ali said that's the
rent that you pay back to God for being
spending time on his earth is to make
this world a better place for all thank
you very much for tuning in we hope that
you enjoyed this week's episode we'll
see you next time until then peace be
with you so long like you don't want to
miss out you want to be here every
Friday and then we
try to give you some short reminders in
between but you can get that if you're
not coming back to the show every week
Friday's will be releasing it God
willing inshallah subscribe right now
and enjoy all of the content that we're
going to be putting out for you thank
you peace be with you so I'm like